digital marketing is more than just a
set of tools or techniques it's a
superpower that can help businesses
connect with customers in ways now
before possible during the pandemic
digital marketing has been a game
changer for companies helping them stay
relevant and connect with customers who
are spending more time at home for
example Pilot's Innovative marketing
strategy to bring gyms to customers
homes Square videos resulted in an
astounding 128 increase in women in
comparison McDonald's somewhere an 18
increase in digital sales by adapting to
digital channels by embracing digital
marketing businesses can unlock their
growth potential by lasting customer
relationships and drive long-term
success did these permanent names
inspire you to make it big
using digital marketing do you also want
to set an example but don't know where
to start well we have good news for you
simply learn scale up codes in digital
marketing can help you stay ahead of the
curve and achieve your business goals
with scale up you will get access to
courses stored by industry experts who
have years of experience in the field
they will guide you through the latest
techniques and trends that help you
apply them to your business and the best
part will see results almost immediately
we'll be able to apply what you learn to
your business and start seeing real
world desserts and if you need help
figuring out where to start a team of
experts is here to help you they will
work with you to identify your business
goals and help you choose the suitable
courses to achieve them so here are the
topics that will help you learn digital
marketing first topic is digital
marketing fundamentals you can start
with learning fundamentals of marketing
like customer life cycle and marketing
Technologies and what it entails for the
future of digital marketing simply
learns skill of course digital marketing
101 will help you do just that and whose
second topic is and 10 Market if you are
looking to improve your content
marketing skills then simply learn skill
up Advanced content marketing course
offers 50 plus or so expert net content
to teach you everything from content
creation to marketing strategy get
certified and Excel in your career today
and if you come on third okay that is
YouTube marketing with the explosive
growth of video as a medium it's crucial
to have the skills to create engaging
videos that will grab your audience's
attention whether you are a business
owner looking to create compelling video
ads or a marketer looking to drive
traffic to a website simply not still up
YouTube and video marketing course as go
to laws and your four topic is search
engine optimization with the help of
Simply let's scale up Advanced SEO
program we will learn Advanced
Techniques in industrial insights and
get practical tips from experienced
professionals with 50 plus hours of
video content exercises and quizzes you
will stay equipped to succeed in the
competitive world of S
Su next topic would be to master your
paper
as fill up course advanced paper tip
program is packed with insights
strategies and techniques to take your
PPC campaigns to the next level you will
learn how to research keywords and
create ads that capture your target
audience's attention paid effectively to
maximize Roi and track conversions to
measure your success so don't let your
PPC campaigns cold flat sign up question
and scale up Advanced PPC program to
start scaling up your profile today now
let's get introduced to the simply
learner where you can easily access all
the scale up courses on smartphone to
the simply learning you can enroll in
free online courses and certifications
that will take you to your next big
Career Training in digital marketing
allows you to handle all aspects of an
enrolled post including course details
contacts and quizzes so what are you
waiting for at your simply lands website
and sign up for a skill up course today
take your business to the next level
with secular I hope this video played
all your doubts about how to learn
digital marketing please let us know in
the comment section below if you still
have any queries subscribe to our
channel for informative videos like this
and thanks for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here